بالتاكيد انت تظن وانت تشاهد بهذه الحلقات
انه لا تاثير على البيئه من قطعه ثيابا
واحده ترتديها لكن هل فكرت فيما يمكن ان
تفعله ما بين 100
و150 مليار قطعه ملابس تنتجها المصانع
سنويا
ما يمكن ان تفعله سنراه الان
حجمه النفايات مهول 92 مليون سنه من
الاقمشه والملابس ينتجها البشر حول العالم
سنويا
الادهى ان هذا الرقم ولا يتوقع ارتفاعه
الى اكثر من 1434 مليون طن في حلول الفين
وثلاثين كارثه البيئيه ضخمه اكثر من 80%
من الملابس المنتجه التي لا يعاد
استخدامها تلقى في مكبات القمامه ثم تتحلل
او تحرق خلال هذه العمليه لا تنبعث من
الملابس كميات كبيره من الكربون والغازات
السامه في الغلاف الجوي للارض والنتيجه
التلوث والاحتباس الحراري
الكارثه ليست فقط في هذه التلال بل خلال
تصنيع الملابس ايضا صناعه الاقمشه تستنزف
الموارد الطبيعيه كل عام يستهلك 93 مليار
متر مكعب من المياه النظيفه ويقطع 70
مليون سنه من الاشجار
خطوه البوليستر وحدها تستهلك 70 مليون
برميل نفط كل عام وهي المصنوعه اصلا من
الوقود الاحفوري وبالمناسبه 65% من
الملابس تحتوي على البوليستر ومنها الجنس
يتجاوز ثلاثه وثلاثين كيلو جرام من
انبعاثات ثاني اكسيد الكربون نسبه 1% فقط
من كل هذه المواد المنتجه يتم اعاده
تدويرها ومن اجل ذلك ظهرت الخطط الخضراء
مبادرات صديقه للبيئه من قبل علامات
التجاريه شهيره في الصناعه الهدف واضح
استخدامها اقمشه معاد تدويرها في جميع
المنتجات
وتقليل هذه الاخطار